More than five million people die each year from smoking,...
...many of them in developing countries.
And Dr. Thomas Frieden says fewer than ten percent of the world's nations are doing enough to prevent it.
The head of the Centers for Disease Control points to the United States and Uruguay...
...as countries whose anti-tobacco programs have worked.
He says other countries should follow their example.
Tobacco is now the world's leading, single cause of death...
...that kills more people than AIDS, TB, and malaria combined.
And unlike those conditions which are decreasing,...
...it is increasing as a cause of death.
But smoking is only one of the world's major problems, Dr. Frieden said,...
...pointing out that traffic accident deaths are becoming an epidemic.
More than one million people are killed in traffic each year, he said,...
...including people who are walking or riding bikes.
What will happen over the next 25, 20 years...
...unless we take urgent action, is that road traffic injuries...
...will increase from two percent of all deaths, to three and a half percent of all deaths.
They will become the 5th leading cause of death around the world.
Dr. Frieden says respiratory infections such as tuberculosis, continue to be another key problem.
He says one billion people do not have access to clean water...
...and two and a half billion do not have adequate sanitation.
He says better access to both would prevent the deaths of millions of people,...
...including children who die from diarrheal disease.
We have cholera still in many parts of the world.
A reflection of the failure to provide clean water and adequate sanitation.